TO BEAT THE BUFFALO SABRES. GAM
NICE ADDITION TO THE LINENET LO
OF HIS OWN TOO MANY SOFT PLAYS.
TIGHTEN IT UP.
LOOKING FOR DUCHENE, ON THE
IS
OVER BY.
NATIONAL TRYING TO PICK UP THE
AND THEY DRAW OD OF BRIDGESTONE
NASHVILLE,
CALL COMING UP, UPON THE
SABRES.
EOC GOING CROSS ICE. PENALTY, G
BATTLES, PHYSICALITY COLTON  YE
MIKAEL GRANLUND PROGRAM THE
LOOKS UP ICE COME
AND OKPOSO WITH THE RIGHT SHOT
STRAIGHT.
>>Chris: THEY MUST HAVE
DUCHENE TRYING TO MAKE A MOVE
UNSUCCESSFULLY.
DUON IT.
>>Chris: NOW THEY IT BACK.
SAROS NOT FOOLED.
DAHLIN SETS  SKINNER HAS
THEY GET IT TO THE LEFT SIDE
DOWN. EY ARE CREATING
MOMENTUM TO CONTINUE
BUFFALO ALREADY HAS A KEY POWER
ONE.
FULL DESPERATION CARRIER RIGHT
MENTIONED, I'VE SEENASIDE AND
T
MYERS WITH THE PENSION,
COUSINS, SAROS, TURNS OUT WIDE.
NIGHT.
PREDATORS HAD TWO PLAYERS THEGO
RIGHT FROM THE GET-GO.
>>Chris: I HATE TO SAY PART OF
THIS, THAT'S FOR SURE.  THE CAP
AND BUFFALO SCORES.